Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god, I can't believe it's been two years.
Oh, Holly!
Oh my god!
Our favorite game, Goddess of Victory, Nikkei, has reached its second year anniversary!
And I'll say thank you, huge thank you, to Nikkei for sponsoring me for today's stream.
For those who don't know, I've actually been sponsored sort of yearly by Nikkei in the past.
Like, I was there during pre-launch, I was there during the first year anniversary, and now we're here for the second year anniversary.
Is that crazy?
The commander is back!
For those who don't know about this game, it's basically, you are a commander, and there's some really pretty ladies here.
But it's okay, they're not real, they're like robots.
So they're like beautiful robot ladies that's trying to save the world, and you are the commander.
And it's all about the gun physics, nothing else.
I was just thinking back about the clip that I did that sort of went viral.
For the gun physics, of course, like, oh my gosh, the guns were so accurate.
The recoil, the shooting, the look of the gun itself, how the gun was held, and how it was shaking and everything.
Wow!
It's all about- oh, and the volume of the gun!
Yes, yes.
So, like I said, huge shout out to Nikkei for- when my staff told me that Nikkei wanted to sponsor me, I was like, do what you can to make sure that I get this sponsor!
Secure it!
Because, like I said, it is a very special sponsor to me, I feel like, because we've been through a lot with Nikkei, so it's really great to be back with the game, you know, being back here, and then a goddess of victory still wants to sponsor me.
At least it's tradition at this point.
Yeah, it is!
It is tradition!
So, I need to remember what to say.
Professional VTuber here.
But yes, this is actually a shooter game.
You control the beautiful anime girls, and each of them has different guns and different utils, different skills, and you control them.
So, before we begin, we're gonna watch a couple of trailers regarding their second year anniversary and the release of their newest character, Cinderella.
So, yes, I know, it sounds like I'm reading off of something.
I'm sorry!
I don't know, I just sound natural.
I'm so sorry!
But there's a new character coming out named Cinderella, and you can actually pull her right now, I believe.
I think she's out.
She was out yesterday.
And you know what's funny?
I don't have access to my old account anymore, so I had to create a new account.
And thank god, I could use my own link.
I can use my own link.
So, please, if you want to support the stream, and if you want to get 200 free pulls, click the link on the description slash pinned on the chat, so you can also get some free pulls from the link itself.
So, you can get 200 free pulls.
So, I don't know, 200 is a lot.
So, like, I used my own link to also create my own account as well.
So, thank god.
Yes, I'm plus one on my own tracking link.
At least, if nobody else uses this, at least I know I used it.
But yes, I actually saw, right, that you guys, a lot of you guys actually got into Nikkei because of me.
Because of the gun physics.
Because, like, two years ago, a lot of you guys got into the not crippling addiction of Nikkei because of me.
And I'll say, good.
And I hope I can get more dragoons into this game.
How is it my fault?
You should be thanking me at this point.
So, for those who've never played this game, don't worry.
You'll know why.
You'll know why some of the dragoons got pulled into um, let's go gambling for this game.
You'll know why after you see the gameplay.
But before we begin, I want to show you guys, I didn't never watch the trailers yet.
So, I want to see, I think one of the first trailer is regarding Cinderella, the newest character.
And then the other one is about their newest animated PV.
So, we're gonna check them out now.
All right, here we go.
Let me know, sound guy, if the volume is too loud or if it's okay.
All right, it should be this.
Whoa.
Mirror, mirror on the wall.
What is the happiest memory?
Oh yeah, because I did.
Okay.
Also, oh my god.
Whoa, they're beautiful.
Also, before we keep going, it just reminded me, because I had to create a new account.
Um, because I had to create a new account, um, I had to re-experience the trauma of the first chapter.
So, I forgot how sad the first chapter was.
I was like, what the... I was just like, what the fuck?
That's the first chapter.
Anyway, so yeah, spoiler warning, but the first chapter is pretty sad.
Spoiler warning.
Mirror, mirror.
Oh, there she is.
What is the most beautiful Oh my god, that's me!
If I, like, didn't dye my hair!
The goddess that fight for mankind.
Mirror, mirror.
Who is the most beautiful person in this world?
You're Cinderella.
You're not, you're not the evil queen.
Oh, oh my god.
Whoa!
I'm looking at her shoes.
I'm looking at... Whoa!
Those are some nice shoes.
Oh, I love it.
I need, like, the... Whoa!
No, it's nice guns.
Nice guns.
Okay, okay, sorry.
Sorry.
With you looking after me, I will stay beautiful for eternity.
Yeah, her weapons are so cool, guys.
Her weapons are so cool.
God, I hope I pull Cinderella.
I don't know how many pulls I get, but, like, I hope I pull Cinderella.
All right.
All right, this is the next trailer.
That was the Cinderella video, which advertises, you know, makes me really want to pull her now, right, guys?
Because of her sick-ass guns.
I don't know, it really makes me want to pull her.
But knowing my gotcha luck, I don't know.
I have very limited pulls here.
All right, this should be... This should be the other video.
And I think this is the animated PV for the story itself.
Wait, does it work?
Guys, why it no work?
Guys, sorry, I didn't test the second video.
The second video, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
The second video is, like, a PV for the animation.
Oh, I know why it didn't work.
Sorry, I didn't test the second video.
Guys, I'm a professional here.
I didn't finish downloading the video.
I am so sorry.
Doing it live.
Wait, what was it called?
What was the video?
Why fast inrev, no download.
It didn't fully download!
I assume it would fully download.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, you guys didn't hear that.
You guys didn't hear it.
Don't worry, I'm downloading it now.
I have fast internet.
I have very fast internet, so do not worry.
Anyway, guys, while we're downloading the second PV, I need you guys to help me for something.
All right, I need you guys to help me.
I want to change the girl on my... I forgot to change the girl on the lobby.
I want to change her.
Oh, nice!
Look at that.
By the way, there's like a ton of bonuses.
Now, oh yeah, by the way, this is like the best time to come back to...
If you haven't played NiKi in a while or if you're a new player, this is the best time.
There's apparently all the stuff you can get from the second year anniversary.
Like, look at it.
I don't even want to read all of this because there's so much.
Like, these are all the stuff you can get right now for coming back to NiKi at the moment.
There's a lot.
I don't even know what Rapunzel is.
Yeah, you get Snow White and... Oh, is that... Which one's Snow White and which one's Rapunzel?
Like, oh my gosh.
Yeah, so there's a lot of stuff you can get.
Recruit vouchers, advanced recruit vouchers, advanced recruit vouchers, advanced... Like, more advanced recruit vouchers.
It's a lot of rolls.
That's what I'm saying.
I'll come back today with my link, of course.
With my link, guys.
Click on the link on my pin chat if you guys want to grab all these free things because they only... Because it only... You can only get it by clicking my link.
Disclaimer, that's not true, but like, just... I'd like to think that.
Oh, again.
I got Pilgrim.
Wait, is this... Oh, I got it!
I got it!
Rapunzel, see?
This is what happens!
Free Rapunzel, right here!
Oh, look at that.
Just as I said, you get free... See?
Just as I said, you get free Rapunzel, right there.
I told you.
You thought I was fucking you guys.
I literally got free Rapunzel.
Look at that.
Whoa.
Also, how do I change her?
Like, I...
How do I change her?
I'm sorry, but like, I literally got... I got new girl.
A new girl, so like, I want a new girl.
Top, right?
Which one?
Which one is it?
Guys, top this one?
The end here?
Is that it?
The four box?
Okay, I don't know what happens if I click that.
Alright, I gotta be sure.
Is it lobby or settings?
Is it lobby?
Oh, it is!
Get out.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna put Rapunzel in here, and then I'm gonna put... Alright, nice.
Okay, save.
Oh my god!
Oh, thank you, Rapunzel.
Rapunzel, Rapunzel.
Let down your...
Let down your... Let down your golden hair.
Sorry, sorry.
Whoa!
Oh, she's freaking out.
Oh, please.
Yes, Rapunzel, can you please pray for me?
Okay, oh, I have so many bonuses.
Oh my god, Aether.
I remember her.
I kept fucking getting...
Guys, okay, this is more so of like trauma, but I don't like Aether because I have PTSD from...
Doing pulls and only getting Aether.
And she's back!
No!
She's back!
No, I thought I got rid of you.
How could you come back?
I thought we were rid of you.
Oh, wait, what's arcade?
Hey, noob.
I know her.
Hey there, Mr. Commander.
Commander.
It's pretty clear why you're all here.
Wait, why?
It's just like old times, but new faces.
You're as perceptive as ever.
Also, I brought up the game a little bit.
Oh, sound guy.
Why don't you take a look at this?
I don't know what the arcade was.
I had to click...
I know I was supposed to check out the second year anniversary stuff, but like, I've never seen the arcade before.
You think that's just an ordinary handheld?
We're very disappointed in you.
It's far more than that.
Oh, I love her little, like, hair tuft here.
It's so cute.
Does it have some kind of special features?
It sure does.
It compiles all the unofficial games floating through the arc.
Wait, consider the dire state of the indie game you're seeing here.
That thing is a godsend.
I don't know why, but I think she sounds like that.
Uh, Nikkei on the first day of November is wild!
Thank you.
It's the true test.
If you guys can make it through today, you can make it through any other day.
It also has automatic updates.
Um, so you don't have to worry about that.
Super cool.
All right, time to pass the baton to Troni.
She'll tell you more about all the tech that went into this bad boy.
What is this?
What is the arcade?
This is a major achievement.
We would be telling as many people about it as possible.
Um, so first I designed the interior casing and circuitry, uh...
Did all the exterior design and UX.
Isira did all the software.
That's about it.
What's the arcade?
Wow, a game console crafted by none other than the arc's most prominent gaming experts?
Amazing!
You really think so?
Nice.
That's what I was wanting to hear.
You bet it's amazing!
Now, what we want you from you is this.
You gotta fire up this console and play games until you can't possibly play anymore.
Wait, I can play video games within the video game?
Perfect!
What is this?
Oh my god!
Wait, that's so cute!
Wait, I wanna play!
Oh my god, wait, what?
Okay, are you ready?
I love barbecues.
I was born ready.
How about you, master?
I'm its commander here.
Good!
Charcoal.
I love barbecue!
I love the arcade.
Wait, when do I play?
Like, is this a game?
Is this?
With pleasure.
Focus!
Fire!
Guys, I'm sorry.
I know I was supposed to check the second year anniversary.
I got distracted.
I'm so sorry.
Guys, please click on the link and help me out so like they can forgive me for not checking out the second year anniversary straight away.
We're the dookies of dookies.
I really enjoy your streams.
Keep on laughing, dookie.
Thank you for the akasuba.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, I should auto it.
You're right.
Be quiet, commander.
Can't you see that Neon is concentrating?
Did you bring the skewers and the ingredients?
Our customers are very particular, so we gotta be sure to include the things they like.
It's ignited!
Good deal!
Commander, I'll put you on skewer duty.
Then Neon will do the cooking.
What will you be doing?
I'll receive our customers.
It's not lucky.
We have thons of wait.
Oh, what?
Thons of customers on this island.
I hereby pronounce our barbecue is un- sorry, we were supposed to do polls too.
But like, oh wait, how do I do this?
Barbecue master?
You haven't reached the target score.
Oh, start.
Customer visits the store every- oh my god, it's like those like cooking... like those- like those like cooking games.
All right, it can't be that difficult, right?
I'm literally just putting stuff on.
All right.
Don't worry, I got you, S.
Oh, fuck.
I already fucked it up.
Um, oh, oh god.
It's out of order.
Is that okay?
Do they really care about the order?
Like, I- whoa, okay.
Stop!
Okay, I feel very pressured already.
Um, what?
Oh my god, what?
I'm sorry.
I'm- okay.
Um, I- I- I give up.
I-
Don't give me up!
No!
I don't want to- get me out of here!
Get me out of here!
Okay, okay.
Okay.
All right, let's-
I realized I was not meant to play that game.
I was- Anyway, let's gotcha!
Wait.
Oh, I get to know my- oh wait, I get to do one recruit a day.
All right, what did I get?
Oh, wouldn't it be cool if I got an SSR off the bat?
Costume gacha?
I don't even have enough...
women for costumes!
Like- Like, what do you mean costume g- I don't even have enough ladies!
Oh my god.
They're like mass-produced too, so it's like they're not a spe- I'm sorry, you're not special.
I'm- I'm so sorry.
You're- you're just...
You're just not special.
Like, what can I say?
You're just- okay, we gotta get Cinderella.
And then this is bonus recruit.
Wait, can I do...
once a day?
Wait, do I have enough?
I do!
Okay, wait.
All right, what are the- oh!
100% chance to get at least one.
Oh, wait, she's so cute!
Wait, I like this.
She's so cute!
And there's like social point.
Oh, is it because you need friends?
Guys, is this the one where you need friends?
I remember this!
You're like, you need friends to get this.
Okay, we're gonna get this one first.
Um, let's see.
How many do I have?
Yeah.
Okay, we're gonna do this first because this one has like...
Uh, wait, what's the probability?
Oh my god.
Okay, we can do this.
All right.
Spend free gems or consume- yes, we're gonna do the- we're gonna do the gems one first because it's 150.
What do you mean no?
What do you mean?
It's 150!
No, go for Cinderella.
Okay, fine.
All right.
What's the probability?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait!
It's not that bad!
Look, look!
It's not that bad, guys.
Look, it says one per- wait, it's guaranteed!
Wait, it's guaranteed!
It's one percent!
Guys, I don't- wait.
Sorry, I forgot.
One percent is not guaranteed.
One percent is one percent!
Oh, oh!
Not that!
Forgot that, like...
It's a gotcha.
Wait!
I got an SSR!
Okay, I got Mika.
Mika?
Uh, oh, she's definitely not.
She's like- she's like default.
Like, nobody cares about her.
Oh my god, no!
Why do I always get Aether?
Why is she always there?
No matter where I go, she's always there!
She carried my head shut up!
I'm Neon and firepower's on point!
Oh, that- she's so cute!
Wait, I like Neon.
I like her outfit.
Soldier EG at your service!
Okay, Aether is- Come on, who is it?
Who is it?
Is it Nirella?
Is it her?
NOOOOOOO!
Victory!
I'm beat!
I mean, it's an SSR, but I like how people are like, oh, Klee.
Like, where's your gun?
Where does your- where does your gun go?
Where do you- oh my- Where does- where does your gun even go?
Like, I don't even know where you can put that!
All right, recruit again.
We got- maybe- maybe this time we'll get Cinderella.
Come on, I just want Cinderella!
This is literally the second- happy second year anniversary!
That's all I asked for!
What'd I get?
Come on, pick two.
Leave it to me.
Three?
Wait, is that rare?
Is three rare?
Oh my god, look at the little cat ears.
Guys, you- guys, use my link, then you can be as lucky.
Whoa!
That's mean!
But like, not blind!
Guys, all I'm saying is that I used my link to create my account.
That's- I use- I use my link to create my account, guys.
So like, if you use my link to create your account, you might be able to get the same luck as me.
That's all I'm saying.
I got three?
That's- It's like 0.4%!
Pilgrim?
Who's that?
I did it!
Second pull.
It's just that easy, guys.
It's literally...
Second pull.
See, I told you, it's 100%.
I don't even need to do any more pulls.
I already got my girl.
The streamer luck is real.
Oh.
Guys, I told you, guys.
Did I get her again?
I got topless on Cinderella.
Oh my god, shit, I can upgrade her!
I can actually upgrade Cinderella too!
Holy shit, that's actually crazy.
I thought it was- Oh my god.
All I'm saying...
This is a new account.
I literally created the account, like, two hours ago, chat.
If you use- All I'm saying, you use the account.
Use the code.
And then, create that account.
Um, four and- Wait, do I need to do more pulls?
I feel like that already got everything I needed.
The salt.
The salt is real.
I mean, I told you, it's 100%.
I did more than 50 and got- Nothing.
I have- Technically, I could do three more pulls.
Get her two more times.
See?
Okay.
All right.
I mean, you know what?
I'll do- Should I do all of it?
Do I- Do I- Do I do it all?
Wait, how much- Wait, let's see.
Where's home?
Uh, lobby.
Wait, what's the costume gotcha?
Do I have enough?
Oh, it's free!
Wait.
Free?
Wait, what's grave?
Wait, it's not free?
Oh, oh, first roll.
Okay, I got the first roll.
What's this?
Oh, nice!
I got beginner maintenance kit.
Nice!
That's free.
Okay, nice.
Okay, now it's not free.
It's not free.
That's fine.
All right.
Wait, who's grave?
Is that another character?
Is that another, uh, Niki that's coming out?
Guys?
No, we're not gonna- We're not- Guys, we're not.
We're not gonna spend more- We're not gonna spend more, guys.
Grave comes next week.
Okay, we're gonna do more pulls then.
We're gonna- We're gonna do more pulls then.
Guys, I can't wait next week, guys.
I can't.
Let's go gambling!
Wait, ticket shop?
Which one's ticket shop?
Which one's the ticket shop?
I don't- Do I have it?
I have cat.
I don't think I- I have to clear the campaign, guys.
Is that- Is that the ticket shop?
Oh, it's in the costume gacha?
Wait, is it these?
Okay, just click that.
Butcher used by commanders to recruit specific Nikis.
Wait, is this like I can get top, middle?
Oh!
Oh, free!
Yeah, I like free stuff.
Let's go.
The cup is filled.
Expense- Exclusive currency for when the event ends.
Unusable.
Wait, I love free stuff.
All right, nice.
Now, what do I do?
Oh, can I use this?
I can roll again!
Oh!
I- I assume the- the magenta is the...
Is the, uh...
No!
This is a scam!
No, I'm joking.
No, it's not.
No, it's- Wait, I got another one.
It's okay.
Come on, come on.
Are you serious?
You're controlling the wheel!
You have to be controlling the wheel.
There's no way!
No, there's no way she has to be controlling the wheel.
It's like the house always wins.
It's like...
The house- The house always wins.
I feel like I'm at a casino again.
All right.
Okay, that's fine.
It's just her.
My gacha luck, though, is insane.
All right.
You know what?
Let's use it up.
Let's do it.
All right, at least the gachas...
At least- At least the gachas fair to me.
At least, like...
At least- At least they're kind to me.
Oh, shit!
Another one?
Let's go!
Hey!
Gacha is so easy.
Like, these are my free pulls, too.
These are- These are my- These are my free- All I'm saying is that I didn't spend any money.
I got paid.
Oh, I got three in a row?
Three, three.
One percent my ass.
Wait, what did I get?
What?
What did I get?
Who's her?
Oh!
Isn't she the one that died?
Wait, she looks just like her.
Diesel, yeah!
That's her!
I remember Diesel!
Oh my god, I remember her!
Oh, she's different.
Oh my god.
No, fuck off, Aether!
Fuck off!
Get out of here!
I don't want you in my fucking- I don't- I don't want you here.
Like, I always- No matter- No matter who I am, you'll always be there, Aether, every single time.
You were there in the first stream, you were there in the second stream, and you're still here today.
She has- I can't- You know what?
Fuck it, let's do it all.
Let's see how far I can get.
Let's use the- Nobody likes her.
Oh, she's not a Maria?
She looks just like her.
I thought it was her.
I was like, wait, I thought you're dead.
Oh.
Oh, okay, not- You know what?
All I'm saying, three in a row was pretty good.
Three in a row was like- Oh god, Neon.
Okay, now I'm gonna hate you too.
Oh my- Whoa.
Whoa.
Where- Oh my god, look how bigger guns are.
Oh my god.
That's a- That gun is huge right here.
You see that?
It's like all the way down here.
Like, all the way down here.
I hate being here.
Oh my- Every pull.
Every pull is here.
It's- Every single pull is here.
Every- She's everywhere.
Whoa, okay.
All right.
How many do I have left?
Last one.
Last one, guys.
What do I get?
I swear, if I get Aether one last time, I'm gonna- I swear to god.
Oh, I swear to god.
If I get Aether one more time, I swear to god.
Oh, another SSR?
Four out of five.
No, don't.
Who'd I get?
Who is it?
Is it new?
New girl?
That's the girl I wanted!
She's so cute!
Oh my god, I like her.
Oh my god, she has like a cap.
Oh, and she has green eyes like me!
Oh my god!
She's so cute!
Novel.
Oh my god, she has- I love her hairstyle.
She's so cute.
She's my favorite.
She's actually my favorite out of all the designs.
Oh my god, okay, all you guys don't care.
You don't matter at that point.
I already got all the girls I need.
The rest of you, you don't matter in my life anymore.
Oh, Delta.
Wow, that was so easy.
Guys, who gotcha so easy?
Like- Oh my god, oh my god, look at my stack team already!
All SSR in just...
five rolls!
Like, all SSR.
All three backtrackers.
Guys, you know what?
I gotta change mine.
I'm gonna change- I'm gonna change mine.
I want her to be my profile.
No, I need people to know that I got Cinderella.
I got Cinderella.
Oh, I should upgrade them.
Wait, okay.
Okay, let's see.
Um, we don't want to look- Oh, I want to look at Cinderella!
Cinderella.
Oh, so...
Oh my gosh, she's so cute!
Oh!
Also, is the game okay?
Is the game audio okay now?
I think like- Where's view mode?
Oh my god, what's her other costume?
Her other costume is so pretty!
Amongst this lambent glass, I too gleam with brilliance.
How do I obtain it?
Oh my god, she's so beautiful right now.
Oh my gosh, she has like a little Cinderella carriage and everything.
Wait, what's this?
How do I shoot her?
Oh my god, it's like Spider-Man!
Oh, and then there's a chibi!
It's just riding around!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Let's see.
Okay, her normal.
Okay, what about her little- The little baby?
The chibi.
What is she doing?
Oh!
Oh, it's like her chibi animation!
All right.
Okay, do I- Okay, how much do I- Can I do the upgrader?
Skill one.
Command, you know how to enhance?
No?
Okay, do I have- I have eight.
Okay, what should I up- Oh my god, I'm...
I'm getting a little- I'm getting a little overwhelmed right now.
There's...
There's so many things to upgrade.
There's- Oh my god.
Wait, I have- Oh, I have her spare body!
I can like limit break it.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Oh my god, there's no way you can get more beautiful, Miss Cinderella.
You're already perfect.
You're- You're already so beautiful.
There's no- You can't get even more beautiful.
You're already so beauti- You know what?
I'll max you out.
Fuck it.
All in!
All in on Cinderella!
It's uh, it's- She's my girl.
I need everyone to know I got her on my second roll.
I- No!
What other girls?
She's literally the main- She's the main girl in the second year anniversary.
All in!
She's- She's literally like the girl right now.
That's right.
Go, go in there, Cinderella.
You'll just be the one person that kills everything.
I'll just make you kill everything.
She really did it.
What do you mean?
She's like- She's my main girl.
My main girl.
I love her.
Why are you staring at me like that?
Because you're cute.
I'm here for you.
How does she shoot?
I miss volume.
I miss her.
No other reason.
I just- I just thought about her.
I- I don't know.
I was just thinking about her, you know?
I was just- I was like, man.
I was just- I was just thinking about her.
Oh, it's so cute.
I should call her.
Yeah, I should.
Me too.
Oh, she's my favorite.
She's so cute.
Oh my god, she has a penguin outfit.
Oh, and a nurse.
Oh, oh my god, her costumes are so cute.
Wait, I love her costumes.
They're so cute.
Yeah, see look at these gun physics.
Look, look at these.
Oh my god, the guns are so accurate.
Oh my god, she's so cute.
I love her.
I love Novel.
She's my favorite.
She's actually my favorite.
All right.
I remember her.
I feel like we've seen her.
Oh my god.
Oh, she has so many new costumes.
She's an OG.
I remember her.
Her costume's so cute too.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
All right, we're only checking the special ones.
The ones that know.
Oh, oh, Rapunzel, Rapunzel, let down your golden hair.
Wear your costume.
Oh, she doesn't have any.
I think she's new, right?
Oh my god, with the power of god.
With the power of god.
Actually using- is this like actually god power?
Like what- what am I- what am I sending out?
Like, oh my god, anime god by my side.
It's over.
Actual anime god by my side.
All right, let's see.
All right, lower music.
Audio.
Uh, all right.
There you go, and it will bring it up overall.
All right, let me know if it's better.
All right, before we do the event, I want to do one game of like the campaign.
Oh, wait.
Old Tales.
We were supposed to do Old Tales.
Fuck, okay.
All right, I- we do one game because I want to do like what it's like with the normal girls.
How strong they are.
I want to know how strong my girls are.
All right.
All right, we go in with Cinderella.
What about the PV?
We'll watch the PV at the end.
Wait, these aren't my girls.
These aren't my girls.
What are they doing here?
Put Cinderella back in here.
Which- what are they doing here?
Wait.
I know.
I know this is a chapter, but still.
Bring back my girls.
Bring them back.
I understand.
Sure.
What was that all about?
I just came up with something.
If the current running through the tracks is the problem...
I love that they can read for me.
True!
So true.
Oh my god, you're so right.
You're so- Oh my god, you're so smart.
Be
burnt to a crisp if they touched it.
How about the auto feature?
Didn't you have more to say?
Commander.
Well...
Yes.
Yep, let's do it.
All right, let's go.
All right, Cinderella, show me what you can- I like how someone was like, why is like everyone's level one?
And then there's Cinderella.
All right, where is she?
Oh, there she is.
They just don't exist.
Whoa, it's so easy.
Where did he go?
Oh my god, I don't know what to say.
Cinderella, I told you.
She's like my girl.
She's literally my girl.
All right, okay, now we do the second year anniversary event.
Now, guys, I just want to know how strong she was, but now, now that- Oh, thank you.
Whoa.
Wait, I just saw the orange eyes.
She really loves god, guys.
Guys, she's really loves god.
That's what- Okay, this is- This should be the- This should be the special event for the second year anniversary, I believe.
All right.
Cinderella!
A sea of red eyes enough to blot out the sky.
A collapsing city.
People dying.
Also, apparently, like- Look, I like joke around about Nikkei stuff, but like apparently the story and the lore of goddess of victory is like actually really sad.
Like- Which is- Yeah.
The death of dignity.
Oh, no, Cinderella.
You okay?
It goes hard.
Which is why like this game has been like incredibly popular, uh, throughout the two years.
I love the character designs of this game and like...
the overall gameplay.
No, Cinderella!
Do you need more upgrades?
Would more upgrades make you happier?
Wait, that's me!
I just look so cool.
That's me!
Guys, I'm a really good voice actor.
Yeah, my voice can go that low.
That's not me!
There's more than one!
Who is he?
There's more than one commander!
Who is this guy?
Showmanship...
Would you like to sing a song with me, Dorothy?
I don't think that'll be necessary.
I said showmanship.
Oh, this is a hundred years ago?
Heading into battle.
Oh, yeah.
No, he's definitely dead.
That's cheating!
Yeah, Red Hood, your magazine is loaded backwards.
How dare you reload?
What's the big deal?
Then it'll just eject backwards.
Oh, that's Snow White!
Showmanship...
There's no way two minutes is enough to show me.
I like how this is all like, um, fairy tale themed.
Crawling doesn't suit me.
I'd rather jump out of the way.
That works, too.
Snow White, nothing's coming out of the staff.
That's because you're holding it upside down.
Oh, whoops.
Is this how I'm supposed to hold it?
Hey, don't point it at me!
As long as you don't sin, you'll be fine.
That doesn't mean pointing it at me instead.
Whoa!
Everyone, we need to get serious about this.
Who's he?
That's not me.
That was a disaster.
It's not fair.
Why does he look like that?
Even though they were far from a well-oiled machine.
Why does he look better than V?
How am I gonna live up to that, guys?
He's so... I'm here, too!
Guys, you can't say that in front of me.
I'm the new commander, guys.
You can't just say that in front of me.
He's not as cool as you, Doki.
He's not as cool as you.
PRS.
We...
We are the goddess of victory.
Humanity's saviors.
That's right.
Me and my beautiful anime girl robots are gonna save the world.
Not him, though.
Get this guy out of here.
There can only be one commander.
Come here.
They set the thing.
No, I promise I won't do anything to you.
They don't try.
They all sat down.
Their exhaustion palpable and visible.
Their bodies were caked in dust and debris.
Really?
They're...
They seem pretty clean right now.
They were the most beautiful thing in the entire world.
I love how Dorothy is just getting...
like...
You don't even... You don't even see her!
Did I fall asleep?
Yeah, you're out like a light.
I was dreaming about the time when I first met the goddess squad.
Is there ever a day when you don't dream about that?
I told you to wait until the test results came out, and here you are sawing logs.
And the results?
As always, you're all clear.
Why do you care?
It's not like we've ever been placed in actual combat before anyway.
All we do is waste time and money.
When can we go out?
Beats me.
All right, get going.
The others have to be tested as well.
Wait, what are we being tested for?
Whoa, who's she?
Whoa!
Why are they...
I don't even... Are they twins?
So you're being deployed?
No, not yet.
They're almost identical twins.
Yeah.
One got... One clearly got more of the protein in the womb.
I get it.
You're bored.
Hang tight.
Good news is coming our way soon.
We think you're lying.
Wait, they're British?
I like how... I like to imagine that because they're like robots, right?
Because they're not real.
You're like, they're real to me, but they're not real.
So like one of them, one of the scientists was like, I want a... I want British twins.
One of the creators was just like, I want them to be British.
So quit standing around and wasting it.
Get in here.
We're coming.
Wait, they used to be human.
Going to...
But they don't feel anything.
Oh, they're real?
It's not like I'm champing at the bit to tussle with raptures, but all this endless...
Oh, so the brains kept the British.
It's exhausting.
We just have to wait a little longer.
The time will come soon...
When we can prove ourselves.
Oh, so like the brains just kept the British.
What are you doing?
HAHAHAHA The British is stored in the brain.
Either one.
Oh my god, so fucking...
You're on high school host club shit.
No, they actually did the fucking...
How can you not know?
How can you not...
How can you not tell which one's Hansel and which one's...
They're not even...
They don't even have the same proportions.
How can you not tell?
How does he not know?
There's a very...
No, they even dress differently.
Alright.
I'm ready to go in.
Oh, we're in.
Something is not adding up.
I'm just like, how can you...
Oh, there's so many...
Oh, it's like it's own area.
The login stamp.
This is more bonus?
More bonus?
Oh, more bonus items!
See, guys?
Look at all these bonus items.
If you use my...
All I'm saying, if you use my code, you can get more bonus items.
Thank you again for DK for the sponsor.
I guess I go to the mirror.
Right?
Can I not just go to the mirror like that?
Oh, please.
You're gonna make me get angry.
You're gonna make me angry.
Alright.
Enter.
Oh!
Her artwork's so pretty!
Like, the artwork is actually so pretty, though.
Can I just auto?
Nice.
Wait, are these my strongest?
I assume they are.
Alright, here we go.
What do you mean where my mouse pointing at?
It's always been the same.
What is it?
Are we going to be deployed in actual combat?
That's the whole point.
That was what the train is for.
And they're not liable to let that go to waste.
When?
I don't know.
Wait.
At this rate, the war will be over by the time we're given the go-ahead.
Of course, when I say that, I mean that we'll lose.
Woah, Hansel!
Oh my gosh, she's so cocky.
Are they not here to science us?
They spent millions of dollars on your bodies!
Like, if you die instantly, it'll be a waste of the taxpayer's money!
That's the whole point!
Are you more of a Hansel or a Cora?
In what ways?
You're making me upset again.
Don't mind her.
Anyway, it's a bit embarrassing for me to be the one saying this.
But our specs exceed that of the original Grimm's prototypes.
Woah!
Yeah, exceeds alright.
Second generation Grimm's models, to be exact.
The sooner you're deployed, the greater our chances of...
How many times do I have to tell you?
We haven't received any orders.
Yeah, like, where will we even deploy you, Red Shoes?
Who would be scrapping us?
What?
If anyone is thinking of scrapping me or Gretel...
I'd like to see them try.
You haven't even got into real combat!
Woah!
Abe!
Damn, Abe!
Damn, what a roast.
Yeah, tell her, Abe.
Every time I get the same answer.
They haven't reached a decision yet.
What hasn't been decided?
We either go out or we don't.
What's so complicated about that?
If it were that easy, we wouldn't be waiting for as long as we have.
You all are the culmination of the finest technology the United Forces of Humanity and VTC has to offer.
Your power is supposed to surpass that of the Goddess Squad themselves.
We can't possibly surpass them.
No way.
I mean, if they put more money into you, I can see that.
Like, they're only as strong as the technology inside them.
If you were made out of the latest technology, then yeah, of course you're gonna exceed.
Yeah, I'll put the volume a little bit more...
VTC.
Updated just now.
There's a whole convoluted web of who contributed what technology, who footed the bill for what, etc.
We're not able to saddle up and ride out like a bunch of cowboys.
Yeah!
Ugh, this is torture!
Do you think this is fun for me?
Like, is killing other things entertainment?
There's other things you can do...
If you're bored.
In order to become a Nikkei girl, you have to endure the experience of a 66% mortality rate.
But let's focus on...
Daddy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Hey, that's a higher gotcha rate than Cinderella.
I'll take my chances.
That's...
That's a very good gotcha rate, not gonna lie.
Wait, who's her?
Who's the little mermaid?
Where did she come from?
Where did the little mermaid come from?
I've never seen her before.
She's just been there.
I guess Hansel and Gretel were just more important.
Oh, is that all she says?
Oh, she's always been there.
That's like her only line.
Don't worry, I'll handle it.
Easiest game of my life.
So easy.
Oh my god, she's so strong.
Oh my god, look at the damage on this.
Everybody else can just die.
Alright, nice.
Target?
Oh, it's him.
Alright, don't worry!
I don't know what else to say!
You do your thing!
Nice.
Easy.
So easy.
I don't get bonus?
How else would you respond?
You would have responded the same way!
How else could you respond to that?
It shows the goddess squad fighting with raptures.
Woah.
Those are Oshis!
Abe just doesn't get it.
She has no Oshis.
All she does is work.
She's a workaholic.
She doesn't know what it's like to work.
She doesn't know what it's like to have an Oshi.
How sad.
Woah!
She doesn't mean that, guys.
You can keep watching me.
She's ignoring me.
She doesn't understand us.
Wait, she's a Nikkei?
Hey, I don't like sleeping.
I'm gonna be a Nikkei.
Oh, but it's a 66% mortality rate.
No, that's fine.
That's fine.
True.
Sounds like me.
You know what?
Sleep is for the weak.
Let's go become a Nikkei.
Either I don't sleep or I sleep forever.
I think it's also because she has no memories, so she has nothing else to hold on to.
Yay!
We can go get killed now!
Oh my god, she can talk?
You fucking liars!
Don't talk.
Wait, what?
Wait, why isn't she allowed to talk?
Wait, was she just acting?
Oh, they're not allowed to talk?
Wait, why aren't they allowed to talk?
I was like, wait, you mean she was acting this entire time?
Oh, talking is her weapon!
Oh, I thought it was just her name.
Oh, it's like she mind controls.
Oh!
Oh, that makes so much more sense.
I thought it was just...
I thought you guys were just saying that as her nickname, as in her actual name.
I was like, oh, that's a funky name, but okay.
Oh, I see.
I was like, oh, she was acting this entire time?
Only one?
Okay.
I mean, to be fair, she's level 40.
To be fair, I put everything on her.
Like, it makes... I mean, she literally has everything on her.
I mean, it makes sense, guys.
I did put all my resources on her.
No fair!
She's literally the main character.
Who else would get the thing?
She's literally the main fucking character.
Of course, she's gonna get everything.
Oh my god.
But yeah, I think I decide... I'm not gonna do the second chapter...
Because that's what you guys are gonna have to do yourself if you wanna find out more about the story.
This... Oh, it's actually been...
It's been amazing to be able to be sponsored by Goddess of Victory Nikkei again.
And if I would, I would play... I definitely wanna play this more off stream.
But huge shoutout to Nikkei for sponsoring it.
And if you guys wanna check out the game yourself, I do have the link in the description and pinned in the comment...
Pinned in the chat box.
So if you use it, you get 200 free rolls.
And I mean, like, literally I created this account, because I don't have my old account anymore.
I literally created this account 2 hours before the stream started.
And I got Cinderella in the second poll.
I got like 4 out of 5...
I mean, I got 3 golden rolls, like 3 SSRs in one roll.
That's actually crazy.
I kept up all my gacha luck for that one roll.
So yeah, if you guys didn't know, here are all the free stuff you're gonna get for the second year anniversary.
And so, there's a lot.
I mean, I literally got Rapunzel from the second year anniversary.
But yeah, you can play on the Google Play Store, you can play on your Windows, you can play on the App Store.
So yeah, please check out Nikkei.
Now let me see if the thing downloaded.
Alright, let's see if I can get the video running.
Let's see, does it work?
Does this video work?
Alright, give me a sec guys.
Oh, yes!
Alright guys, before we end it, let's watch the video.
I have no idea what this video... what it is.
Alright.
Oh, it's the red one!
Oh, the animation is so pretty!
Oh my god!
I love the music.
The music is so good.
Oh, it's Cinderella!
How?
You're level 40!
I put everything into you, Cinderella!
Yeah, Nikkei has such great music.
I
only learned how to raise your voice, did you?
I don't think guns work at this point.
Like, would guns work against other goddesses?
Gods can bleed.
True.
Party's over.
Oh my god.
That was a sick animated PV.
The animation was so good.
Oh yeah!
Wow!
Thank you again!
Thank you again, Nikkei, for sponsoring me.
It actually was great to be able to go back, you know, come back to Nikkei.
I feel like it's more like a yearly event now.
If I'm back... I hope I get to be back for the third year anniversary, that's for sure.
Unfortunately, we weren't able to... Wait, can you pull volume?
Is there a chance?
To pull volume?
Like, serious question here.
Like, if I do this... If I do this...
Oh, I don't have... Nevermind, I don't.
I don't have enough.
I was gonna say, like... Wait, can I pull volume here?
Technically?
Yeah?
Okay, wait.
How do I... Okay.
Bonus recruit?
Wait, what does this mean?
Details...
Use a hundred to... Oh!
I can set up a wishlist?
Where do I set it up?
Wait, where's the wishlist?
I don't remember how to do it.
I wanna...
No!
I had to do 40!
I'll just do this.
I did it.
It's okay, I'll do one free pull.
Maybe I'll be lucky.
Maybe... Maybe... I don't know at all.
It's her.
No, I just... I just wouldn't.
I wouldn't.
I miss her.
I miss her so much.
She was what got... She was what started our Nikkei career.
She started our Nikkei career.
No!
I got Ape!
Wait, I can check her out?
How?
Wait.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, where is she?
Where is she?
I miss her.
I miss her so much.
Oh wait, she's so cute!
Wait, who's her?
Oh, she's so cute!
Oh my god, I love her outfit.
Wait, she's me!
Wait!
That's literally me!
That's okay.
Wait a minute.
Wait, Quincy?
Who's Quincy?
Oh, no, that's Quarry.
Quincy.
I want volume, but volume's my girl.
I think it's more... Oh, this one.
She's famous.
She's definitely famous.
Where is she?
Oh my god, noise!
I missed you.
Oh my god, she's my favorite.
I don't know if you guys know that.
I love Nikkei.
She's my favorite.
She started my Nikkei career.
She started my Nikkei career, guys.
I owe it to her.
I owe everything to her.
Anyway,
guys.
Thank you all for coming to my Goddess of Victory Nikkei stream.
I really appreciate Nikkei for...
What do you think you wish?
This is my SSR.
It was great revisiting back to Nikkei again.
Thank you again to Nikkei for sponsoring me.
I hope you guys enjoyed.
It's like evolution, guys.
I basically just evolved chat.
Thank you everybody for coming.
Check out Cinderella and Propunza are both available now and Grave will be available next week.
Use the link in my description or pin in the comment if you guys want to do some polls.
You get 200 free polls if you click on that link and create an account.
You already saw that I was very lucky with those polls because I used the exact same link.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
I think Nikkei in general has a really good story and also music.
The story and music in Nikkei is really good and the character design as well.
I mean, look at me.
Bye!